this is one of the worst Road collisions
ever seen in Kenya a truck driver who
was transporting cement lost control of
the vehicle rammed onto other cars and
motorcycles killed many roadside Traders
and injured others police are searching
for the driver who fled from the scene
Witnesses said he was speeding
I just got to the junction I saw a
speeding oncoming trailer I swerved and
escaped hitting him head on the person
who was behind me thought I wanted to
buy something he overtook me and that is
when he was hit
I was in londonia town my wife works
here at the junction that's how I got
the news firsthand I rushed here and
found people being rushed to hospital
others were still under the trailer
sections of this road from Nairobi to
Western Kenya are dangerous for drivers
because of sharp corners and bands as
the weather is often cloudy with poor
visibility
many traffic accidents have happened on
this road Traders and hookers sell their
merchandise to motorists along it and
often obstructs traffic as I rush to
look for buyers
transport cabinet secretary keep chumba
more common visited the scene and said
that will change
we will relocate the traders to
designated Market areas we will pave
access roads to make sure they can sell
their produce but they cannot continue
to do their business on the highway
some Canyons say enforcing traffic rules
is difficult because of reckless driving
by some motorists police corruption and
poor maintained roads the national
transport and Safety Authority say more
than 4 000 people were killed in Road
accidents in Kenya last year for now
many people in londiani are grieving
struggling to come to terms with what
happened Catherine soy Al Jazeera
Nairobi Kenya